hi I'm Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer question from one of
my newsletter readers transferred who
runs a web development web design in
software development company and one of
my advice on how to go after and get
bigger customers on board so trust heard
it's a great marketing strategy I love
working with bigger clients if you can
especially in the early days of your
company you'll find that they can give
you the cash flow to get your business
up and running they are usually a little
bit more demanding than individual
customers sometimes not but if you can
get them to see you as a really
important resource for their company
you're going to be an ongoing supplier
for them so the smaller guys may use you
here and there it's hard to rely on that
income but the larger guys if they see
you is really important they're going to
want to keep hiring you back and back a
box it's a great way to get recurring
revenue which is awesome for an
entrepreneur who's just kind of getting
going with their company so in terms of
you been able to get bigger customers
for your business the first thing I
would do is talk to your biggest
customer right now look at your top
three customers there's a size and the
amount of work they do with you and get
close to them and understand what it is
that you know really drives or business
how you might be able to help them up
with other projects that they may not
have thought about Mickey casual take
them up to lunch you know give them
suggestions on how they can grow their
business beyond just how you can help
them but the idea here is to really get
to know your customers understand their
pains or problems and then you can
develop solutions you will help them so
you might be able to grow with your
existing customer base your bigger ones
and do more work with them it's easiest
way to kind of grow your businesses some
more the current customers the second
thing I would do is look at the three
service that you offer you said web
development web design and software
development and see which one of those
could be your thin wedge into the market
so if you're looking at targeting bigger
companies which of those three could you
offer as a quick intro package let the
customer get to know you work with you a
big risk for these companies is they
don't want to work with someone who's
going to let them down and there's a lot
of switching costs between getting a new
supplier on board
so what can really help is if you have a
really simple easy low cost low risk way
to start doing business with somebody
even a really small project so if maybe
you're doing a landing page or a quick
app for them something that is really
easy for you to do doesn't cost a lot
for them low risk situation get them to
work with you get them to like you and
trust you and see that you're over
delivering you're providing tons of
value make sure you are over delivering
like crazy on the project and then it's
easy to get them to give you bigger
budgets on going so gently work with
other suppliers may not be happy with
them if they see that you're doing some
work on a small scale with them and
they're really liking it then they're
gonna want to hire you back get more
projects continue increasing the budgets
and do my work view so it's an
investment in a relationship you may do
the first one even not at a huge profit
just to kind of get in there show them
the kind of work that you can do but
figure out from those three what could
be your thin wedge in to the market and
once you start working with them then
it's easier to kind of get more and more
work from them the last thing I would do
is try to partner up so see who else is
selling to your current market and how
can you work with them so look at people
who have related businesses they're
targeting you're seeing customer base
they already have an established base of
those customers that you can find some
way to be able to work with them if it's
a referral program or they're taking a
commission or whatever it is fine guys
are already selling to your target
market and find ways to partner up with
them to be able to have them introduce
you to the customers and then you can
use your thin wedge into the market
strategy to help continue that
relationship physical form so good luck
I hope that helps remember to talk your
current customers your biggest ones try
to do more work with them and understand
their pain points to look at your
services see what can be the easiest way
in small project low risk just to get
them working with you and then they see
their value late you bring they're going
to do more with you and three partner up
fine guys are already selling through
target market and see this ways you can
work together so I hope that helps
transferred if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I love
seeing those thumbs ups come in and it
makes me want to do more of these videos
so thank you and I'd love to hear we
have to think if you want to leave a
comment underneath the video if you
liked the video or not or if you have
other suggestions to trust
are the things that I work for your
company I'd love to hear it so please
leave a comment below and we'll see you
on the next episode
you